hey how's it going bro this is Peter Pan
Pokemon go I can't stop playing I'm
level 25
my legs hurt though what does everyone
one from Pokemon go what is the one
thing that we're all missing that's
right to play from your computer that's
what we're gonna do today hey now you
may think we hacked the game [ __ ] that
we're not cheaters right Michael we're
not you that's right we're not cheating
might say I bought one of these very
expensive drones uh to shoot video with
I I could the audio I was allowed to
borrow this but if I break it she's
literally going to kill me so we're
gonna put my phone on this and we're
gonna play pokemon go remotely let's do
it so 13 days ago someone posted this I
didn't see it until now so someone has
already attempted this but we don't have
any proof right we're gonna actually do
this [ __ ] he's asking is this cheating
we're about to find out we're gonna duct
tape my samsung s7 I love so dearly to
these very other expensive pieces of
equipment
hopefully nothing goes wrong let's do it
so now right now I am duct taping my
phone underneath the drone as securely
as I can I'm actually really nervous but
I think that's pretty good actually I
got a whole stupid idea this is by far
the best one so the idea the idea is
that the drone is gonna move us to a
location where there's a lot of pokemons
then there's a program by my computer
where I'll be sitting here controlling
the drone looking at the footage while
at the same time I'll see my screen on
my computer catching pokemons the way
the game was made this is how nintendo
envisioned this game to be played
everyone now there are a couple things
that may or may not go wrong is it
powerful enough to lift this phone I
don't know it's the phone gonna stick
these are very powerful fans
Oh could this go wrong yes let's just
keep let's do it this is do it there's
only one way to find out Lissa's do it
update firmware don't make me laugh
alright here we go there we are hi we're
live
alright drone make me proud now go and
catch some pokemons bring our phone
that's on the drone opening the Pokemon
Go app oh we got a lot of drowsies
nearby oh it's making clicks and [ __ ] I
didn't click for that maybe the tape is
like [ __ ] up the display a little bit
we ran into a problem right away the
touchscreen is [ __ ] because of the
tape so we have to put something in
between luckily we found one of these
fits perfectly no touch screen is
working who needs a $30 case when I put
app I can make one for you uh just 29.99
alright much better quality sec oh look
Tom this is looking like a [ __ ] bomb
doesn't it
alright time to fly
my sis gonna kill me if I [ __ ] this up
let's not [ __ ] it up the drone is
stabilized
okay here we go we're flying freestyle
oh my [ __ ] god I'm sweating I am
sweating
[ __ ] oh my transmission gun know how
I'd sail is still there we're switching
phones because the Samsung is so maybe
it's the edge screen I don't know but
it's so sensitive to like touch touch or
whatever even though we pet try and pack
it nicely so we're gonna try it with a
Sony see if that works as well
plus I got this one for free so if it
falls off it's less of a pain honestly
I'm surprised but in doing this right
before what do you think about this oh
yeah this should work right books that's
pretty good why did we not do this this
is like that looks [ __ ] good this
looks like a pro did it look at that
[ __ ] we've been going for about an hour
and a half so far we put the phone in
the air but no poking up alright it's
gonna rain soon starting up the camera
realizes that I can't move
Oh No
come on camera I told you we have to
move it backwards a little bit maybe so
cute you think this is funny you think
this is funny
goddammit
alright Michael thinks it's okay yeah
we're in geez
get me my [ __ ] chair is there alright
now we're gonna get over there there we
go
where are the pokemons let's put let's
put a fete on now
I'm pretty good man oh we got a drazi
here we go
swiping
we got it okay we got it in the poke
ball we got it yeah where's the drug
seriously okay
oh god it's going so high okay we got
what we came for
for a [ __ ] drowsy man let's get this
baby home safe
landing oh yeah we got a drowsy I can't
[ __ ] there it is
[ __ ] drop oh dude now I know how they
felt like when they landed on the moon
alright so we did it we caught a Pokemon
while using a drone I know it's not much
but I still think that was pretty cool I
didn't think we would actually be able
to do it this is my second time ever
flying a drone and I was kind of scared
of just losing the drone if you have
more experiences with drones you could
totally pull this off especially if you
want to hatch eggs Hey but that was
pretty much it I hope you bros enjoyed
it like and we might try some more weird
[ __ ] like this and it's always thanks
for watching
stay awesome breasts they don't have a
catchy
Berenice oh my god oh my god cameraman
been a pleasure working by your side but
once I go away now won't make you back
what do you mean doing since we pick it
what it's nothing